Je pars ce soir chercher Natsu au Japon et j'ai reçu ça ce matin ! C'est tout ce dont j'ai besoin pour bien m'occuper de lui donc
on ouvre la vidéo sur ça, c'est très bien !
Aaahh !
Hop là ! Le colis est énorme, j'ai jamais reçu un colis aussi gros.
(Voilà ceci était un mensonge) qui contient uniquement des choses pour des animaux, qui contient aussi beaucoup d'espaces vides ! Voilà y'a plus rien dedans.
Excellent ! Je sais pas si ce plan est bien, je pense qu'il est vraiment nul à chier. Et là je réalise vraiment à ce moment
précis que je vais avoir un chien dans très peu de temps.
Premier élément : une serviette en microfibre. A quoi va-t-elle servir ?
Et bien lorsque tu transportes ton chien dans un sac, il est mieux qu'il soit...
euh.. bien inst-...
Quel chat fait du bruit là ?! Donc on en prend deux, comme ça quand tu es en train d'en laver une, l'autre est disponible. Excellent !
Oh, ça, c'est des friandises pour récompenser ton chien quand il fait quelque chose de bien.
C'est quoi ça déjà ? Oh c'est mignon, c'est une petite trousse de secours ! Alors... Ah ça.. c'est de la bouffe. La laisse !
La première laisse de ma vie !
J'ai pris une laisse où il n'y a pas de... Attend, on dirait vraiment un youtubeur canin... J'ai pris une laisse basique, tu vois, un mètre
cinquante, elle peut faire, pour le balader basiquement. Et avec cette laisse, qu'est ce que j'ai ? Un petit harnais ! C'est beaucoup plus petit que...
Je crois que je me suis trompé de taille !
J'ai vraiment pris le harnais pour les petits caniches, les Shibas je pense que ça correspond à cette taille là. J'ai vraiment fait de la
merde ! Jumbo ? (rires)
Jumbo, vient voir, vient voir vite fait. Et voilà, un merveilleux chat que je peux désormais balader en laisse.
Oh non, il aime pas le pauvre, noon !
Oh il aime pas du tout, il est fâché. Ah oui ! Important, un coussin ! J'en ai pris un taille immense pour que
les chats puissent se poser avec lui, et qu'ils se fassent tous des bisous et qu'on soit une belle famille, bien soudée et très heureuse.
Là, il est petit mais après il va grandir de ouf donc voilà. Petite corde !
C'est un jouet, finalement. Bon voilà, et là on a des croquettes voilà, pour chiots. Des croquettes de bonne marque,
attention, achetez bien de la nourriture de qualité pour vos animaux
car c'est la source principale de problèmes de santé,
il faut le savoir. Tout ça pour vous dire qu'on a maintenant tout ce qu'il nous faut.. sauf le chien
donc c'est un peu le plus important... A tout de suite... euh... au Japon
Eh bien, bonjour ! Comment allez vous ? Moi ça va extrêmement bien. Nous sommes actuellement vendredi matin, je suis arrivée au japon hier soir et la
première chose que je vais faire c'est aller voir Natsu on attend ça depuis maintenant trois semaines on va partir maintenant on va le rejoindre
et on va tous chialer parce qu'on va être ému ! C'est parti
Nous nous approchons actuellement de l'endroit où Natsu se trouve j'ai le coeur qui bat vite, je suis très ému
Eh Natsu ! Comment tu va ? comment tu vas mon pote ? t'as grandi , tu es
un grand bonhomme, tu as grandi
Comment tu vas ?  t'as grandi ! Non, lâche mon pull, tu m'as manqué, ça va mon pote, trois semaines, trois semaines que je t'ai pas vu
T'as l'air heureux ! je crois que tu m'as reconnu. J'pense que tu m'as reconnu je sais pas mais...
Ah, tu détruis mon pull ça marche. Bon, les amis, Natsu a grandi de malade
regardez ça regardez moi ce grand bonhomme, il m'a reconnu je suis trop content il m'a fait une fête de malade. Dès qu'un chien s'approche
de moi il veut le bouffer parce qu'il est jaloux, je me demande comment ça va être avec les chats
Aie ! il tire la (be)barbe, il aime pas la bebar, je vais me raser j'ai compris, j'ai compris ! Il est trop heureux, il a vraiment grandi
je pense qui fait deux fois la taille de quand je l'avais vu la dernière fois. On va sortir on va faire une balade mon
chien. Ouiiii ! Depuis le temps ! Regarde ça, regarde ça comme il est heureux, ça c'est pas un chien heureux ça ? qui montrent le bidon
Non, laisse mes lacets en paix, tu vas arrêter de tout démolir
tu vas attendre d'être à la maison pour tout démolir. Tu vas me racheter des Adidas après par contre ça je te le dis oh !
il vous dit bonjour c'est bien Natsu t'es déjà un très bon youtubeur (rires)
laisse ma caméra laisse ma caméra tu dois me racheter des Adidas et une caméra déjà allez on va se balader.C'est partit mon grand. allons nous
balader dans ma ville préférée
Fait gaffe y'a une petit bosse mon pote. j'ai peur ce qu'il se blesse, j'suis un papa gaga
ça va, il écoute bien j'ai lu un peu des techniques quand ils font chier en laisse, ce qu'il faut faire et tout, je me souviens de rien, mais j'ai
j'ai lu, hein.
Il me regarde le pauvre.Et attention, la première merde de chien que je nettoie de ma vie ! On y va !
Ce n'est que le début. Le problème c'est qu'y a pas de poubelles à Tokyo, t'es obligé de le mettre dans ton sac à dos
à toi. C'était la première balade avec Natsu j'espère qu'elle vous aura plu.
Il y en aura d'autres je pense qu'à un moment on ira à Kamakura dans le sable. J'ai trop hâte des prochaines balades.
Voilà j'espère que cette première vous a plu
Je sais pas si je vais refilmer aujourd'hui je vais profiter un maximum avec lui
auquel cas je vous fais plein de bisous je vous dis à très vite au revoir
Et bien bonjour les amis il fait beau nous sortons de deux jours de pluie Natsu n'a pas pu sortir
et là il est complètement excités parce qu'il va pouvoir aller au parc à chiens du parc Yoyogi,
un enclos avec des chiens de sa taille. 'Fin j'espère qu'il aura des chiens parce qu'on est lundi
après-midi j'espère qu'il y a des Jap' qui travaillent pas. Il va s'éclater, gambader, s'amuser.
C'est toujours un bon moment. Tu vois ton chien heureux comme jamais et je découvre un peu la sensation ces gens ont à sortir avec
leurs chiens, être content, parce qu'ils voient leur chien heureux, je me sens un peu pareil
Après j'avoue je risque à tout moment de faire un arrêt cardiaque puisque je cours à coté de lui comme un con.
Il veut trop aller vers les gros. Eh Natsu !
T'es un petit caca n'oublie pas mon grand. Faut que je le fasse redescendre, parce ce que sinon il va prendre la grosse tête comme son maître après.
Il a fait un terrier mon gars il a gratté mais de ouf. Ici, là. Et si ça se trouve, mon chien
il trouve les trésors mon gars !
Bon les amis c'est la fin de la balade ça fait une heure et demie, deux heures à peu près qu'on est là c'est bien, il s'est
bien dépensé. J'ai acheté un sac dans une boutique en face du parc c'est un sac à dos et je pouvoir le balader avec moi grâce
à ça. C'est la première fois qu'on le met dedans, attention. Voyons voir comment il le prend.
Oh là là les amis, je suis le mec le plus gaga du monde attention :
C'est génial !
On est bien ou pas ? Imagine moi sur le scoot comme ça direction mon bureau pour tourner est-ce que même il kiffe un peu il se
dit putain je me balade mais sans faire d'effort physique c'est bien ça, c'est aussi le début de l'obésité, attention. Natsu tu dis à demain ?
Allez, dis à demain.
oooh
Bonsoir chers amis. On est sur une petite mine. Pourquoi on est sur une petite mine ? Parce qu'hier on s'en est prise une, une mine
olala on commence sur la beauferie aujourd'hui
hier soir c'était Halloween à Tokyo, je l'ai fêté à ~Shibuya~, au milieu de 1 milliard de japonais, j'ai vu des mecs arriver dans des
caisses tunées en mode Tokyo Drift et en fait ils étaient hyper sympa, tellement sympa qui nous ont fait faire un tour
Le problème c'est que mon conducteur parlait pas un mot d'anglais donc quand je le filmais et il savait pas trop comment réagir le pauvre
J'ai aussi croisé des gens qui étaient chargés de ramasser les poubelles, des éboueurs finalement, qui étaient déguisés en Mario et Luigi
Aujourd'hui on est où, on est à Kamakura. Il y a pas mal de temples ici il y a aussi
"The Great Bouddha", une statue de bouddha qui fait 13 mètres de haut et 121 tonnes, c'est juste incroyable.
La plage est à seulement 300 mètres d'ici donc on va clairement y aller. Il faut que je prenne un café entre temps
putain je suis rentré très tard hier d'Halloween mais c'était incroyable bordel.
C'est génial, en arrivant sur la plage, y'a une pancarte qui t'averti des tsunamis : "En cas de tremblement de terre
attention aux tsunamis qu'il va provoquer"
Ils te disent qu'en gros même s'il y a pas d'alarme, il peut y avoir un tsunami plus ou moins gros qui arrive donc faut être attentif et,
et remarquer s'il y a des choses étranges. P'tain c'est flippant ! Alors attention, attend, je te retire ça.T'es prêt à courir ? Tu es libre !
Alors j'ai une frayeur nulle, de maître nul. J'ai peur qu'un de ses énormes oiseaux le choppe et s'envole avec.
Natsu s'est fait des potes sur la plage ça c'est beau ça.
Demain dernier jour au Japon avant le retour.
Le but ça va être qu'il se dépense un max pour que, dans l'avion, il dorme le plus possible
Je suis anxieux mais pas trop, puisqu'il est très cool et très calme.
je sais au moins qu'il fera pas chier les autres passagers du vol. Comment va-t-il réagir face au chat de la maison ? c'est la grosse
question. Ah, j'suis mort.
Ca y est, il est chez moi.
Bon, je vais pas vous mentir, j'ai pas filmé l'arrivée dans l'appartement parce qu'après douze heures de vol j'étais un peu mort, mais
en tout cas dans l'avion ça s'est trop bien passé
Natsu n'a pas hurlé une fois, il a été le chien le plus gentiiiil. Et en arrivant à l'appartement en fait les chats se sont juste
planqué. J'interdis à Natsu l'accès à la chambre donc les chats se réfugient dedans, après ils ont pas l'air d'avoir peur
plus que ça en vrai. Mais bon l'acclimatation va mettre plusieurs jours c'est normal. Est-ce que vous avez remarqué mon petit Kimono
stylé ? Hein ?
Eh tu fais quoi toi, t'es gymnaste ? T'as fais trois ans de gym ? Enfin bon voilà ça fait bizarre de l'avoir à la maison je réalise toujours pas. Je suis
un peu parano j'ai toujours l'impression qu'il s'ennuie, ou qu'il est triste parce qu'il est plus au Japon
Alors qu'en vrai, je pense qu'ils s'en fout mais je ne sais pas, j'ai trop peur pour lui, je l'aime tellement. Je suis vraiment gaga de
ce chien c'est très très grave il faudrait un numéro d'aide pour les gens trop gaga de leurs animaux. Tu as de la pisse sur
la patte je le sens et c'est humide !
C'est bien de la pisse. Alors il pisse là dessus à la maison, hein, croyez pas qu'il pisse par terre... Hé ! Mon chien il est bien
éduqué, ok !? Je vous dis à très vite et à bientôt dans une prochaine vidéo.je vous aime, Natsu vous aime.
Alors aimez vous vous-même. C'est le pire outro...
Correction des affreux sous-titres par Schizo Pathe